today we're gonna talk about three
different things one of them is how
Arnold Schwarzenegger used to brand mr.
Olympia to jumpstart his career two
we're gonna talk about who the current
Joe Weider is and three what would
happen to the mr. Olympia brand if Danny
Garcia and Dwayne Johnson were to take
over the brand so let's get right into
the first thing I want to ask you is the
following here's what the question is
ready what Arnold Schwarzenegger with
this King Kong personality who is in
Hollywood movie star marries the Kennedy
is worth a few hundred million dollars
would he be who he is today without the
brand of mr. Olympia and him winning
over Joe Weider
would he become the same person that he
is today your answer may be there's no
way in the world he won mr. Olympia then
everybody said look at this guy's
physique then Joey to put him into
Hollywood and he became a star right so
let's go and look at his rise to the top
and what formula he used very simple
first he comes to the US then he wins
mr. Olympia then it becomes a face of
bodybuilding then he wins over Joe
Weider this is why it's written here who
replaced Joe Weider
he wins over Joe Weider Joe Weider is a
magnetic personality big personality of
visionary charming charismatic Hollywood
all the stars in Hollywood want her to
become bodybuilders and have nice
physique and Steve Reeves and looked at
the physique he had and oh my gosh I won
over Joe Weider the moment Arnold won
over Joe Weider Joe all of a sudden open
up his contacts to him so Arnold through
Joe's contact said I'm gonna go into his
contacts in Hollywood and see what I can
do so he kept working his ass off he
became a good mr. Olympia citizen hey
Joe Weider mr. Olympia is great I'm so
proud to represent the brand then he
started doing movies then he married a
Kennedy then he starts businesses then
he goes into politics he makes hundreds
of millions of dollars and will leave a
massive legacy behind not just in the
bodybuilding world but period a massive
legacy behind in us in bodybuilding in
Hollywood in politics he's going to be
remembered hundreds of years from now
that's the formula that Arnold use now
what is today's formula number one build
a massive social media brand now keep
this in mind any of these things I'm
talking about this doesn't apply to
everybody
this applies if you have a physique if
you're willing to pay the price if
you're willing to go through the things
you need to do to win minstrel Olympia
at least be one of those guys that wants
to compete is it worth you putting your
body through what you need to win put
through to win a mr. Olympia so number
one build your social media following
I've got a million two followers on
Instagram I got three million followers
on Facebook you got a great physique
people are following you number two come
to the States and win mr. Olympia if you
wouldn't once they'll say well you gotta
win a few more to win three more if you
and Ford they'll say well you gotta win
four more didn't go in four more then
you marry you Jones you don't marry a
Kennedy right then contact whose context
you buying two who is today's Joe Weider
who is really building their brand word
they are connected to Hollywood so what
are you gonna go into do you have to do
all the work yourself he didn't do all
the work himself he paid a price but he
got close to this guy remember the Joe
Weider of mr. Olympian basketball would
be a guy like Jerry Buss Magic Johnson
won his context and he went in there's a
very big factor here that a lot of
people don't think about so who is that
Joe Weider today so there is no context
then what do you do maybe you start a
supplement company right and starting
the supplement companies so many people
have started and it's not like the
ingredients are massively different like
you found something special but you
white label a brand and you have a loyal
following and you start a supplement
company then you start doing some
surgeries maybe to your bones maybe to
your knees because you done so much
squats maybe to your stomach maybe all
maybe all of these searchers that you're
doing to try to recover from then you
only leave a legacy behind in the
bodybuilding world so what ends up
happening is they become expensive
glorified trainers training other people
that want to be in stro limp used to
follow this formula and they start a
podcast does that sound like a formula
you want to put your body through and to
follow are you okay with this right now
a lot of people watching us they're
gonna say well Pat Arnold wanted to go
into her body but you know Hollywood or
not wanted to do that I there's a lot of
people that wanted to follow that
formula but you need a contact you need
to win over a person like this yet this
is
very very critical right let's continue
okay so now say mr. Olympia bran is
watching this and they're saying I hope
nobody else sees this because what if
what about the bodybuilders watch this
what if guys that are competing for mr.
Olympia watch this well here's an
alternative what if this were to happen
what if Dwayne Johnson and Danny Garcia
were to take over mr. Olympia what if
they were what if they could they took
over mr. Olympia and they both loved
bodybuilding there's a passion for it
it's not a business it's a passion then
a business not a business to just make
money and let me take over for wheter
there's nothing worse than somebody
replacing where the passion isn't at the
level of the guy that started it there's
got to be a passion for the vision Danny
Garcia just competed and you guys know
doing Johnson loves bodybuilding he
takes care of his physique he's one of
the only guys in Hollywood outside of
Arnold that got so big
and you had a physique and people said
you can't be a major Hollywood celebrity
being that big there just isn't enough
roles for you two guys proved everybody
wrong one is this guy and one is the
rock so say today they buy the brand
here's what it will look like number one
you still build your social media
following
number two you still win mr. Olympia
number three you win over Rock and Danni
by becoming a what a good citizen then
you go into their contact similar over
here you know what their contacts are
worldwide and wide spread into anything
you want money business finance us-china
Hollywood shoes sports athletic wear
what do you want it's everywhere right
then you marry whoever you want to marry
because you're in there if you want to
get married you marry whoever you want
to marry movies not only do you get into
possible movies if you have the
personality which a lot of these guys do
you get into movies then if you get into
movies you don't just get into the US
market because Rock's been able to tap
into the US market and worldwide market
and China market then outside of that
what do you do not just start a
supplement company for what why do I
need to start a supplement company you
can start it if you want to that's great
but even bigger than that guess what you
do you start signing contracts and deals
but Under Armour can you imagine a
bodybuilder signing contracts with Under
Armour
outside of just the typical things a
bodybuilder sign up with what if the
first bodybuilder sign a major contract
with Nike or Under Armour think about
that and these guys could do it you mean
to tell me Under Armour now goes into
the bodybuilding world because they're
brought so much exposure to them
worldwide do you know how big the
bodybuilding Brandes worldwide but they
need better people to run it so let's
continue with this then you don't make
10 millions because Arnold made hundreds
of millions if your run rates gonna be
60 years 50 years 40 years you have the
potential to make billions not millions
billions because it's that big you
better believe the rock at this pace is
going to be a billionaire this guy's not
gonna be worth a few hundred million
he's on track to being a billionaire not
a millionaire right they're not Saturday
you get access to the best doctors
because that's the best doctors they
have and then you go into politics if
you want to you don't have to if you
don't want to and last but not least you
don't just leave a legacy in the
bodybuilding world you don't just leave
a massive legacy in us you live a
massive legacy worldwide because their
brand is a world wide so now if you're
watching this somebody says why I just
don't think the mr. Olympia brand can
ever get that big I agree because I
think there's a few things that need to
take place let me explain to what I
think needs to happen you can agree or
disagree but in recent sit downs with
Phil Heath with Dorian Yates and with
Brandon Currie the brand new Cruiser
2019 champion you know during eights as
a six-time and Phil Heath as a
seven-time I brought out one of the
biggest challenges that I think we
missed or Olympia brand is facing and
here's what it is it's a it's still
uncomfortable to say bodybuilders use PD
or all that other stuff right one of the
best things if they could take a play
out of the PlayBook of what Rogan did
there used to be a time thirty years ago
we're smoking marijuana was like owns
you know it's bad it's this a status
that listen I don't consume myself I
don't smoke weed I don't take CBD I
don't take an I don't take anything
myself but Rogan who's a smart guy he's
a very smart guy he's not just the guy
that's a personality guy he's a very
smart guy he brings the brand and brings
attention to saying listen let's do some
study let's do some research let's start
ask you're looking into it and outside
that I guess what if I want to put it in
my body as a libertarian let me do it
it's not your business I want to put it
my body to the point with Ron Paul and
other politicians Republicans Democrat
independent said just make sense let
them do what they want to do so if if
mr. Olympia wanted to go the complete
other route what I'm talking mainly my
route is they got to come out and say
stop saying we just use creatine and
supplements and protein listen we all
know you can't look like Hercules by
just eating create and improper
supplements and protein and amino acids
you got to put some stuff through your
body but so what people are talking
about trt now this like trt is nothing
you didn't talk about trt 25 years ago
today it's different they call it you
know anti-aging type of stuff right now
again I'm not endorsing any of this
stuff all I'm saying to you is for this
brand to grow the mr. Olympia brand to
grow at this pace it's going to die
because it's a lot easier for me to just
have a big social media following get
sponsorships for the amount of following
guy have then go to Kuwait and put all
this stuff through my body then have to
do surgery on my knees my back and then
I have the gut and I have all this other
stuff done I don't want to deal with
that I'll just make six hundred thousand
dollars you know sponsorships then have
to go through this rut but in order for
it to work you got two enemies one you
got to address the steroid and pedia
epidemic you have to talk about that and
it has to be transparent and number two
you need a Joe Weider because you're
missing that Joe Weider
if you have the Joe Weider and if you've
addressed the other issue now somebody
could say you know what let's find out a
little bit more maybe it's not gonna be
NBC maybe it's not gonna be some of that
but maybe it's gonna be shown mr.
Olympia on HBO
maybe it's gonna be shown on some of
those other channels and maybe you know
mr. Olympia is gonna be on Netflix if
somebody like him does it it could
happen then it gives more exposure to
dowse come to those competing and then
the price goes up to millions luck Conor
started off UFC they were paying
fighters $5,000 $10,000 $2,500 $10,000
London then Ronda Rousey and Conor
McGregor come the brand explodes now
guys are getting paid real money to
fight can you imagine if this happens
then bodybuilders who are putting their
body through what they're putting
through now you can actually start
making a million two million five
million ten million per year now you can
explain and say this is why I do what I
do with bodybuilding and this is why
it's worth it or else this mr. Olympia
brand that the vision
the charismatic the incredible Joe
Weider started many many years ago well
one day very soon become irrelevant if
it goes the way it's going today if you
agree or disagree
comment below send me a direct tweet at
Patrick made David I will respond you
got two other videos I want you to watch
one is with Brandon Currie we got into
this topic just a couple weeks ago he
was a little bit uncomfortable but we
did go into it he's a twenty nine to mr.
Olympia and if you want to go a little
bit deeper spoke or watch my interview
with Dorian Yates and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel do so this is
not a bodybuilding channel this is the
number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs I just enjoyed this
industry of bodybuilding and that's what
I want to do this video thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]